watching this year's
short documentary films i'm reminded by
how much impact good storytelling can
have at any length
colette introduces us to a 90 year old
french resistance fighter whose then
17 year old brother also in the
resistance
was sent to a german concentration camp
by the nazis
a concerto is a conversation
is a gorgeous tribute to grandfather who
made it possible for his family
to dream the biggest of dreams
hunger ward takes us inside a clinic
in yemen the result is as dizzying
and as disorienting as war itself
embedded inside the hong kong protests
for
do not split the filmmaker's approach is
deeply collaborative
sophia nali allison's experimental
documentary
a love song for latasha is a meditation
on life
and joy in the south central
neighborhood where she spent
her childhood
and the academy award for best
documentary short
goes to
colette anthony aquino and elise
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you to the academy um i hope the
actors in the
room don't mind that uh i have something
written down here because
they're all different kinds of people in
the academy um
today is colette's birthday she was born
just 22 days before the very first
oscars in 1929.
so i imagine it must have been a
probably about a crowd about this big
right
you know uh when she
when we got nominated she told us that
uh or she reminded us that the power of
documentary filmmaking ensured that her
brother
jean-pierre was as she put it no longer
lost in the night and fog of the
nazi concentration camp system
and i want to say that i think it's the
that same power of the documentary
storytelling that is going to uh
ensure that the memory courage and
resilience
of latasha harland's
horus bowers the innocent
children of yemen and the protesters in
hong kong are not forgotten
i mean that's why we do this that's why
we make these films so
thank you thank you uh we're grateful
that these stories and these individuals
have been honored tonight
and i also um
would just like to thank of course
colette and lucy i want to thank our
amazing ep peter hirschman
at electronic arts everyone at
electronic arts and respawn
and oculus especially vince dusty and
laura
and our producers annie small and aaron
matthews thank you so much
to the guardians charlie phillips jess
gormley and lindsey poulton we
share we share this award with you
and um i just add something um
this award is a tribute and this film is
a tribute to women
everywhere in the world of any ages
that who are joining hands and fight
for justice with colette
vivla france thank you
you